dgap-news e mail
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde paintball und es gibt im
moment los geht los das ist ein
spielprinzip wieder auf dem gleichen
server wie auch sumo ist allerdings
besser als sumo finde ich bin im team
rot ist sieht man daran dass er seinen
roten block ab dass sie sind so ein paar
hütchen da kann man sich hinter
verstecken und wir müssen das blaue team
besiegen wir haben schneebälle und
müssen die mit rechts auf das andere
team werfen
und wer halt zuerst weniger leute hat
halt dann verloren so und man muss
vorsichtig sein weil ich glaube jeder
hat nur zwei leben ich bin zum ersten
mal
also ich bin ja nicht so ein typ der
hier alles zu 1000 mal testet und dann
euch nur die besten runden liefert ich
mache das so einfach mit euch entdecke
ich das bisschen community mäßigen
relativ dunkel hier das ein bisschen
doof
es ist immer wenn ich so man kann auch
mit rechts ins schleudern
man kann auch mit links hinten links
klick schleudern da war ich dann schon
recht verwirkt
also paintball nennt sich das ganze soll
wie in der beschreibung bevor wieder
alle fragen höre wie spielt man das
lokal war doch mal so sind die blauen
jede runde geht übrigens gleich 2 100
sekunden
wenn ich mich nicht ganz irre sind denn
jemand paar blaue hallo hallo bmz märz
haft ich sehe hier gar kein hallo
freunde sind neue blaue helligkeit
verarschen
oder gibt es irgendwie auch noch was
unterirdisches von dem ich nichts weiß
an die das wahrscheinlich anderen tätern
ist dahin schießen
etwas verwirrt nils oliver sind desto
langweiliger runde
hier sind überall rote ich bin ja auch
roth
die blauen hallo freunde keine
entschuldigungen rhapsody may - ein
freund was heißt das jetzt 90 sekunden
lässt toll ja ich weiss anderthalb
minuten haben jetzt noch übrig aber was
bringt uns das wenn ihr kein gegner ist
das wisse gab es überhaupt gegner ich es
gab ja ganz kurz am anfang habe ich mal
welche gesehen wie egal wir warten das
jetzt mal einfach ab wahrscheinlich
versteckt sich jetzt irgendwo einer
oli p
minute based on point
also das ist ja witzig wenn wir das
jetzt direkt bewunderten klang geht es
jetzt nicht noch zu drei sekunden drei
sekunden
da sind so viele neu herausgekommen
hätte setzen auf neue blaue 20 sekunden
ja da müssten wir eigentlich gewinnen
das war mein erster sieg also tut mir
leid dass diese erste ein bisschen
schwammig bzw schlecht war aber wir
haben gewonnen drei anscheinend aber
gewonnen
komm ich mal wieder bei random heißt
julian dem team das heißt egal ich bin
wieder rot heißt und 10 es geht los
und es kommen einfach keine blauen doch
da hinten sind blaue also ich habe jetzt
ich bin tot baumann ich hatte vielleicht
nicht so offensiv reingehen wir sollen
also der nachteil eine sache man hat
halt nur ein leben das ist halt so die
sache naja also man sieht dem chat ist
dann auch relativ heftig grad am
verrecken sind ich versuche mir so ein
bisschen den parcours zu meistern in
einem durch wünschen uns ist ja an sich
ja ok hab ich doch bei manchen stellen
muss man einfach warten wir das dann so
eine kurve geht
hilft man nochmal kommt einmal schauen
wir noch das so heftig dass wirklich die
meisten einfach am ersten sprung schon
schaltern und da unten stehen als auch
dass meine minecraft in den köpfen von
anderen leuten ob man allerdings auch so
pb random neun rennen team 2 5 4 3 2 1
los komm geht immer vor jetzt hier
ich habe nur ein leben mission kommen ja
auch irgendwie durch irgendwie durch die
kanalisation oder so kommen nicht
scheiße
warum laufe ich denn hier rein
ich verlege die nicht direkt im nacken
wurde ich will doch nicht direkt wieder
so schnell sterben
ich glaube das lässt sich nicht
vermeiden so die sind auf dem anderen
schiff jetzt
da stand eine rübergegangen 0 gegen aue
läuft einfach mal direkt im anschluss
rhein kein ding bru
k n d so wie komme ich darüber
schön einfach mal so ein bisschen dieses
wasser nach josef ronja das ja schön pb
random nicht mal ein paar runden
einander packen wer cool finde ich wenn
man mehrere leben hätte das wird es dann
jedoch bevorzugen wo ich glaube ich noch
ein paar runden auf so dass wir dann
zehn minuten voll hamburger sohn dann
aber dann auch eine vernünftige zeit
konnte denn jetzt
wie gesagt ich werde dann auch zum
ersten mal konnte verkenne ich jetzt
auch ein gar nicht
ein bisschen signalfeuer ja genau ich
habe auf einmal wieder ein team welt
getroffen weil ich mich dann verhalten
irgendwo die mit getroffen
als es jetzt weil der gold ist das jetzt
bei mir so dass das jetzt der gegner
doch das war ein gegner oder der wahl
der vier team sondern
nein und ich sage nochmal bbc
februar dauert wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen länger glaube ich war einfach
geil ich würde
ich bin im team rot
da kommt noch immer vorab dass die map
von vorhin ja cool die scheiße läuft vor
los ich sehe einfach mal gar nichts
das spiel das wir gerade bei richtig
heller sonne einfach von daher es ist
übelst kalt draußen aber die sonne
scheint das wieder so crazy german
das kann doch nicht sein es kann das
knie war sein
ich stelle mich dahinter warten bis er
kommt knall ihn ab und dann packe ich
einfach trotzdem ich glaube ich wollte
einfach dabei bleiben dass sich auf
youtube videos hochladen wie schlafe na
gut vorne das was von meiner seite aus
ich hoffe euch jetzt ein bisschen
gefallen
paypal hätte ich mir jetzt mehr von
erwarte ich teste das ja gerade hier so
alles mit euch diese ganze spiele
deswegen ja auch sumo gestern
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder wenn es ihnen dieses mal gibt
vielleicht welche sterben oder so weil
ich irgendwie vom auto überfahren werde
ich weiß es nicht kann ja mal passieren